[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone it's joanna here so
whenever we think about strength
training we always think about lifting
weights but the fact is that you can
strength train without lifting any
weights so your body weight acts as
resistance today's workout is going to
be a total body strength training
without any weight we will be doing drop
sets so there will be a total of four
sets the first set we want to aim for 20
repetitions second set 15 repetitions
third set 10 repetitions and the final
set will be 5 repetitions so your goal
is to complete the entire workout in
your shortest time possible let's do it
[Music]
this workout is going to be a low impact
workout so there's no jumping involved
and it will be gentle on your knees the
first set will be 20 repetitions first
workout let's do prisoner squats so i
want you to place both hands behind your
head okay stand shoulder width apart
toes pointer forward and give me a nice
deep squat good really push your butt
back and down and push up with your
heels okay so imagine you're sitting and
really pushing up with the heels the
whole reason to keep both hands behind
your head is so that you will be opening
up your chest and avoid doing this okay
no hunching forward keep it open
nice and deep
very good push up with your heels not
with your toes five more one
two last three
last two
and last one good now let's get down
onto the floor and work on our upper
body your favorite workout push-ups
so we want to do both
wide to narrow push-ups okay so let's
start with white push-up okay that's one
step in too narrow to really work on
your triceps good
so if you find this to be challenging
remember you can always stop
on your knees
good keep going narrow really point your
elbows back
again
there are always easier options okay
onto your knees and then bring it in
good
wide
and narrow nice remember to always keep
your body in line do not stick your butt
out this is wrong okay keep your body in
line
lower down
last three more
good
we want to go for another tumor okay
white
narrow
and done
next workout
lunges instead of your normal forward or
back lunge we want to combine both okay
so let's start with our right leg
hands by your waist step forward
that's
one okay immediately kick to your back
two
good three
so remember again
proper form is extremely important so
keep your chest up
back straight
and find your balance good
you will really be working on both legs
okay
so bend down lower your body to a 90
degree angle good
keep going
you should be feeling your
left legs
more
nice if you can't balance step
and step okay take a small step and step
good
step and step as you progress wide step
forward
wide step back
five more
we got four more okay stay strong
last three
last two
and one more
one
and back
good shake it out
now that you have done your right leg
let's move on to the other side your
left leg okay so same thing
stand shoulder width apart toes pointer
forward you should feel your heart rate
going up so let's take a wide step
forward
and back good
forward
and back nice
pace your breathing to find your balance
look straight ahead okay
good forward
and back nice forward
and back again if you struggle to find
your balance step
back
step
forward
step
back
very nice
and as you progress
take a wide step forward and back whoa
i can feel my thighs burning
you're halfway there
wide step
chest up
do not sacrifice your form okay you can
slow down the workout but do not
sacrifice
your form
keep going
last five
last four
three more guys three more
three
last two
and one more
let's go left
and back
oh my god
give your leg a good pad check it out
next
we're still focusing on our lower body
but i want you to work on the inner
thighs and also your calves so stand
wide
next workout is sumo squat on toes so
stand wide in a wide position toes
pointed out tiptoe
give me a nice deep sumo squat okay you
should really feel your inner thighs
working that's three
again 20 reps okay four
five you can place your hands just right
in front of you tiptoe all the way do
not bring
your heels down to really work on your
calf muscles
halfway there
find your balance stuck in your car to
really find that balance good
whoa
feel your calves muscle as well
last five
four
three last two keep your back straight
last one
down and up
shake it out
now let's move on to our upper body
so i want to work on your lower back
muscles and also your core muscle so
let's get down onto the floor
next workout will be superman to plank
okay
so face down
this is how we're gonna do it
one up superman push up to a plank
that's one okay let's go up
push up good
up squeeze your lower back good
remember as you push up come up as one
unit good
superman
and up
keep your core strong your upper body is
strong
okay face down
squeeze
push up good
my sweat is dripping
i'm feeling
absolutely
sore
but good
who says
we need weights to do strength training
squeeze your lower back hold it push up
squeeze
push up good
squeeze
and up
keep going squeeze
push up
squeeze
and up last five
let's go one
up
strong arms strong upper body two strong
car
stuck in those car three
last two
four
[Music]
and one more
up
and up
whoa take a short break
wipe your sweat if you need to okay
i'm absolutely
drenched right now
oh see you on your plank cross plank so
get into a plank position
just give me one cross okay that's one
that's two so opposite side three
good
knee to elbow
knee to elbow
keep going
keep your base strong okay keep your
elbows slightly bent
stay strong guys this is your second
last workout
stay strong stay with me
[Music]
last few more
and last one
very good
and
oh my god
it's like raining right now
let's do one last final workout okay
knee tucks so
sit on your butt
all right relax your upper body
and let's get straight into a knee tuck
one
two simple knee tuck three
four
knee two chest five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten last ten
one
two strong core three
four
five
well done and now i just want you to
get into a child pose
that is your first set 20 repetitions
done
[Music]
i'm already drenched in sweat so let's
move on to the second set which is 15
repetitions at this time you know the
workout so let's get straight into it
first workout prisoner squats okay toes
pointer forward hands back let's go
let's get into a nice deep squat really
squeeze and push your butt back okay
squeeze those butt muscles push up with
your heels
good
toes pointer forward look straight ahead
chest open good
keep going last five five
four
three last two
two
and one shake it up down onto the floor
okay wide to narrow push-ups choose your
option let's go body straight
one
in
two
out
good you're going to challenge yourself
you can even hop out and in okay
again it's all about creating variation
to make your workout that little bit
harder good
elbows pointed back keep going last five
four
last three
last two and give me one more wide
push-up down and up
very good
let's get into lunges your favorite
right leg first okay
so remember forward and back choose your
option let's go
back
that's one remember look straight ahead
to find your balance good
knees close to the floor
good
really work on engaging the opposite leg
as you move forward and back
keep going
stand shoulder width apart
find your balance strengthen your core
to really keep you
in a straight line good
you should feel left thighs burning
last five more
five
push back
four
last three more three
two
here's your breathing
last one
and back
oh my god
let's shake it out now let's move on to
the left side so keep your right leg in
the same position and just move your
left forward and back good forward
and back very nice
again it's all about finding your focus
point and finding the center of your car
again beginners take a step
step
touch and step okay
as you progress
then really push
forward
and back power up those thighs you have
strong thighs you just need to work on
them
last five five
last four
keep going
lower down last three
go low
last two one more
really go low and push up up
down up
shake it out
one final
lower body workout sumo squat
tip toes okay on your toes so stand wide
toes pointed out
get into a white sumo squat position
lift your heels off and let's go down
one only fifteen two squeeze the inner
thighs three
four really squeeze this muscle five
six good
heels up seven
eight
nine heels up
ten squeeze the cuffs
one
last four more two
three
last two
four
last one down
and up
shake shake shake
and let's get down onto the floor let's
work on our lower back muscles
alright superman to plank okay
ready hands
forward face down squeeze your lower
back push up good
squeeze
and up
squeeze
and up good
tighten your car come up in one straight
line
as much as possible okay
and up
beginners again if this is challenging
armor to your knees and back down
squeeze
and up
keep going
i can see my sweat
dripping
and you should be able to see
yours as well
five
let's go last four more
okay
up do not stop now
three
up
last two
one more guys one more
squeeze
and up
very
very
well done
last two workout okay
oh my god
swell
it's just going into my eyes right now
let's do it plank cross cross
and cross over that's one okay remember
to bend your elbows slightly so do not
lock your elbows
too much good cross and feel your
obliques working very good
keep going
twist and twist last five five
four
three
last two
one more one
and
shake it out
let's sit on our butt
one last workout and you will get a
short break okay
let's do it
call workout
knee tucks relax your upper body find
that balance and let's go one
two
three really tuck it in four
five
six
seven
eight stay strong stay with me ten last
five do not drop now stay strong last
three
last two
last
one
my favorite part
get into
child's pose
and just relax
[Music]
oh my god if you want to
get yourself hydrated drink some water
wipe your sweat
you're halfway there we want to move on
to the third set only 10 repetitions so
let's get back up and let's start with
the first workout which is prisoner
squats hands back toes forward let's go
one
deep squat okay do not sacrifice proper
form i know you're tired i'm tired as
well but it's all about aiming for
proper form last four
last three guys deep squat open up your
elbows last
and one more give me one more up and
rest it out
let's go into
our upper body workout wide to narrow
push up okay challenge yourself get onto
your toes if you want to let's go
one
in
narrow elbows pointed back
good
very nice elbows back
three tighten the core keep your body
straight
two more
give me last two on each side okay white
oh my god my triceps are burning
and
[Music]
sit out
let's move on to lower body again lunges
okay let's start with our right side
forward and back let's go
one
good find your balance
pace your breathing okay
do not rush your breathing the more you
pace your breathing the better you are
at performing your workout and the
longer you will be able to go
last five
last four
and don't forget to smile
last three
[Music]
last two
you got this
and last one
back and up
shake it out a little bit
swap legs okay
it is okay to look like this that means
working hard
let's go left forward
and back
keep your right leg
stationary good bend your knees
good
look at my sweat on the mat
keep going
last five more
breathe in your nose out through your
mouth
last three more
go low
and push up
go low
push up last one go low push up and
shake it out
sumo squat
tiptoe okay stand wide
toes pointed out go wide if you can and
go lower if you can all right ready
heels up let's go one
go lower two
really squeeze those inner thighs in
your car
three
last
few more keep going
give me five more okay
one
two
three engage your cows as well
four last one stay down hold
and ah
very nice
and now let's get down
into superman
to plank
oh my god
look at that that's my face
sweat okay let's do it
right up squeeze your lower back up okay
your lower back is also part
of your core
muscle
three good push up
up
very nice in one straight line okay
breathe out as you push up
good last five more five
up
four
good
last three more guys
it's all about counting down
two more squeeze look up
one more
squeeze as high as you can
and push up
very nice
let's not stop now let's get straight
into cross plank okay stay with me stay
strong
all right cross elbow to knee
five more halfway there
you're almost there
last two
one hold one and release
onto your butt
oh one last workout and you have one
more set
this is real
i'm doing this workout without stopping
okay let's get into it
one two
three
four
five
six extend all the way seven
eight
nine
ten
well done cross
forward
child's pose
you have done three sets you have done
20 15 10 reps final set five reps okay
you got this so let's count together
throughout this entire round ready let's
go prisoner squad wipe your sweat wipe
your sweat and go one count with me two
three
four
five
straight into push-up one narrow
two
wide three
narrow four last one five
straight into lunges let's go
one
two full of energy guys
three power it up
four
last one
five
swap let's go
one
two
good three
four
last one five
next
sumo squad
tiptoe okay
those up ready let's go one
wider two three
four
five
down
superman to play
very good see how fast you can go
one
two
three
[Music]
four
five
straight
one
two
three
four
five guess what
one last workout
knee tucks
one
two
three
four and five
very very
very
well done
now you can take a longer child's pose
you can go grab some water
wipe your sweat because you have done so
well
that's your total body strength training
without any weights okay choose your
variation and slowly progress by
choosing the harder option
do this workout at least
three to four times weekly and trust me
you will start to feel stronger you will
start to notice that your body will
start toning up and of course
you will
be drenched in sweat okay don't forget
to share this video with your friends
like this video subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more workout videos
crazy workout challenges and also
fitness tips do also turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time
i am sweating and i want you to sweat
with me all the best